>> LAURA: MUELLER TESTIMONY
SUCH A MASSIVE DISASTER THAT
EVEN THE MOST HARDENED LIBERAL
RESISTANCE MEMBERS COULDN'T HELP
,  BUT TWEET THEIR
HEARTBREAK.
JUST LIKE HOLLYWOOD AND THE
DEMOCRATS DID THEIR DRAMATIC
READINGS OF THE MUELLER REPORT
REMEMBER THAT?
WE WILL DO THE SAME WITH THEIR
SAD SAD SAD TWEETS.
DISGRACED AND HE TRUMP LAW
PROFESSOR WROTE FAR FROM
BREATHING LIFE INTO HIS REPORT,
THEY'RE TIRED ROBERT MUELLER
SUCKED THE LIFE OUT OF IT.
FORMER OBAMA CHIEF STRATEGIST
ADDING THIS IS VERY VERY PAINFUL
.
FORMER CBS ANCHOR DAN RATHER
TWEETING TO THINK THAT ROBERT
MUELLER SHOULD BE THE MAIN ACTO
IN THE DRAMA WAS ALWAYS
MISPLACED CASTING.